monsieur le ministre en septembre
dernier vous aviez annoncé quels
allaient être les dépenses et puis vous
aviez confié le travail à votre majorité
pour trouver des économies vous avez
rendu une copie blanche c'est à dire 0
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui
entraîner aussi doctement que vous le
présentez à l'instant votre finalement
votre méthode et votre stratégie
jamais la France depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale n'a connu un tel niveau
d'endettement est-ce vrai ou faux c'est
juste une réalité nous allons emprunter
270 milliards d'euros c'est du jamais vu
cette année en 2023 avec des taux
d'intérêt qui remontent donc on se
retrouve en grande difficulté la France
se retrouve en difficulté au moment où
nos partenaires européens ont eux
conduit un certain nombre d'efforts
nous sommes en queue de peloton sur un
certain nombre de grands indicateurs
d'être Public Record prélèvement
obligatoire record déficit public qui
nous mettent sur le podium européen
envolée du déficit commercial ça ne peut
pas durer c'est l'affaire des Français
monsieur le ministre je l'ai dit vous
avez pris finalement un carton rouge et
la France par contre ne peut pas être
hors-jeu elle ne peut pas rester hors
jeu alors monsieur le ministre pour
conclure à quand des économies merci
[Musique]